welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and moon knight finally revealed
the hidden history of mark spector and
his dissociative identity disorder but
one cryptic detail in that flashback has
many of us wondering whether kanchu
might have been possessing mark from
long before the two seem to meet has
kanchu actually been manipulating mark
the whole time oh my god hey one final
chance to get yourself a moon knight
inspired tomb of the moon god shirt over
at newrockstarsmerch.com it's really the
best way you can support what we do here
at new rockstars so in the episode 5
flashbacks steven follows young mark and
his brother randall from their family
barbecue to the cave and then steven
steps on this bird skeleton deliberately
meant to evoke the appearance of conscu
it's a perplexing clue as this incident
is otherwise presented to be the actual
cause of the abuse that mark's mother
inflicts upon him which causes his d.i.d
a fully separate chapter of his
backstory from mark's adulthood
encounter with konshu after the
mercenary incident so why are we seeing
this khanshu clue this early well one
explanation is that this memory is still
a subjective organizing principle one
access through the door of mark and
steven's psych ward and visual elements
within this memory are still surreal and
warped in a way in order to help steven
and mark make sense of it in this case
the bird skeleton could be meant to help
the altars link this tragic origin with
the vulnerability that konshu would
later prey upon and maybe the reason
stephen and mark perceive konchu as a
withered skeleton despite konchu's fully
feathered birdhead in egyptian art is
because of this grim omen from that
traumatic memory but there is also
evidence that konshu might have targeted
mark from a younger age because this
series is heavily inspired by the jeff
lemire run of the comics which suggests
that konchu might have first found mark
as a boy but like most things in that
awesome run even that is presented to be
an unreliable claim maybe a false
projection created by konshu whenever
mark looks back on his childhood this
episode frames the reliability debate in
an interesting line from harrow do you
think you created stephen
to hide
from all the awful things you feel
you've done in your life or do you think
steven created mark to punish the world
for what your mother did to you yes hero
opposes this as a chicken in the egg
query who created whom harrow's asking
this as a manifestation of mark's inner
doubt about whether he used the primary
or the altar but the question could also
be framed around mark's origin was
mark's condition the result of a
childhood trauma that sent him on a path
to khanshu or could konchu have created
the conditions of mark's childhood
trauma right before konshu takes
position of mark he says
what a waste
and goes on to say your mind
i feel it
fractured
broken
most fascinating
you
are a worthy candidate to serve me
during this time yes conscious prayed on
mark because his d.i.d made him
vulnerable to which steven criticizes
that sneaky old vulture
he was manipulating you from the start
no i kept us alive
mark he was he was taking advantage of
you or it was just a way for me to keep
being whatever always been
a killer so could the words from the
start mean that konchu could have
groomed mark ever since they stepped
over those bird bones outside the cave
could it even be possible for konshu to
foresee how that would lead mark to
inevitably crawl bleeding up into his
tomb the issue was seeing the bird
skeleton as an outside surreal delusion
sneaking into an otherwise legitimate
memory is that it's not the only
illogical thing about this flashback
sequence it opens with randall coloring
his drawing of a one finned fish
obviously not to gus so then did steven
later on as an adult buy an actual fish
with one fin despite the pet store
owners saying none of their fish were
one finned and even stranger later on
the day of mark's abuse in mark's
bedroom is that same drawing framed on
the wall except it's now not fully
colored in whereas randall had totally
finished coloring it in fully that
drawing was an original sketch by
randall not something ripped out of a
coloring book he drew it with one fin
and it is the same exact drawing not a
replication by mark i don't think this
is a production mistake they showed us a
close-up of that drawing before when
randall was clearly alive and then
framed on the wall an incomplete version
in a scene that could only take place
after randall's death not to mention the
other oddities of this flashback
sequence like us never actually seen the
boys inside that cave and never seen
young mark escaping from it and the fact
that they are in urban chicago within
walking distance of a heavily wooded
area with easily floodable death caves
like chicago does not have caves like
that yes later steven says that they are
on milwaukee avenue which does go on to
border some forest preserves in northern
chicago but none of those preserves have
stephen king death caves that flood in
minutes folks tunnels creeks sure but
caves no also this street is a weirdly
sparse studio backlot no extras no
traffic they didn't even try to populate
it it's exactly the kind of set wand
division shot on to intentionally evoke
artificiality now staring at hidden
clues on screens all day can lead to
sore eyes and problems sleeping blue
light damages our eyes and leads to
digital eye strain the symptoms of which
can include blurred vision headaches and
dry watery eyes for some folks this can
even affect your energy level well blue
blocks was created to fix this problem
and block out the blue light with high
quality lenses thanks to blue blocks for
sponsoring this video blue blocks
computer glasses are evidence-backed and
made under optics laboratory conditions
in australia when i'm spending time and
fluorescent lighting staring at screens
these glasses are a big help they have
over 40 styles of frames and come in
prescription non-prescription and
readers blue blocks also has other
amazing products like red light therapy
devices and sleep masks they ship
worldwide in rapid time and make returns
and exchanges easy so go to
blueblocks.com new rockstars and use
coupon code new rockstars to save 20
that's blueblox.com b-l-u-b-l-o-x
dot com new rockstars and use the coupon
code new rockstars to save 20
now our buddy ryan airy over at screen
crush posed a really cool theory that
konchu might have gone so far as to have
been the one who actually killed randall
oh
man he makes a pretty strong case i just
wonder if that revelation would make
konshu so evil that mark would have to
permanently reject him and then we would
have no oscar isaac moon knight in the
mcu and they didn't make those action
figures for nothing you know they spent
money on this they're gonna want oscar
isaac in midnight sons with all of his
cool conscious superpowers so rather
than khanshu evilly grooming mark all
along carefully steering mark along a
series of life events that would have
led him to being a mercenary bleeding in
that particular spot in front of a
statue i think the bird bones are
evidence of konshu influencing mark's
perception of his past and instead
konchu might be planting in mark's mind
a false altered memory about how
everything really went down now yes i
still think mark's mother abused him and
that was the origin of his d.i.d i just
think it would be weird for the show to
go to the length to include that dark
scene just to turn around and reveal it
as a false history in fact if this
finale suggests that major parts of this
heartbreaking backstory were a delusion
it's gonna be a rough whiplash either
way now in the lemire smallwood comics
that this series is heavily based on the
actual origin of mark's d.i.d was him
discovering family friend rabbi itz
perlman was secretly a nazi named ernst
a racist serial killer now head writer
jeremy slater told our colleague joanna
robinson on the amazing house of our
ringerverse podcast that he deliberately
steered away from that backstory to
avoid having to depict hate crimes which
is totally understandable and i think we
can all agree mark's abusive mother is
traumatic enough but it's also worth
remembering that in the comics randall
spector or rand does not die he actually
goes on to become the villain shadow
knight now there are a lot of ways that
we can interpret why we don't see the
boys in that flooding cave like it is a
production headache to film children
underwater regulations requiring scuba
divers to replenish air every few
seconds but it's also just possible that
randall's body was never found and that
he was believed to be lost and wendy
responded to that by abusing mark and i
actually think randall's unexplained
disappearance better parallels gus the
fish whom stephen woke up to find gun
mysteriously given no explanation on how
exactly and was even told that he never
had that fish to begin with we could
look at randall the same way the one
finned nemo who was never found lost to
the depths and now mark's organizing
principle reframes that confusion in the
form of this fish drawing as an
incomplete one in his room symbolizing
his unfulfilled closure so do we need an
evil not actually dead brother shadow
knight randall to show up in the finale
that might feel like something out of
the page of dexter who realized that the
ice truck killer was the brother he
didn't know was still alive i personally
prefer randall's disappearance to be
left a mystery like he may have just
drowned he may have flushed out into
lake michigan he may have been claimed
by pennywise and turned into shadow
knight to return in midnight suns in the
future but for now the ambiguity makes
for a stronger story for mark who
nevertheless suffered the consequences
of losing randall and now as mark looks
back on those memories he reframes them
in a way so that his supernatural deity
protector was by his side all along to
give a semblance of order to an
otherwise chaotic and random tragedy so
ultimately i don't know if kanchu was
actually there at mark's side the whole
time but either he or mark are
definitely projecting khan shu far
enough back into a memory to cast doubt
on that entire history and if memory as
a concept is however our present minds
frame the past to best fortify our
present then yeah who's to say khanshu
wasn't there the whole time you can
follow me on instagram and twitter ea
boss follow me rockstars subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you